OVERHIRING:
Almost every major tech company in
the world likes to claim that they operate like a
startup. Despite being worth hundreds of billions
or even trillions, these companies like to
claim that nothing has changed in terms of their
company culture relative to when they began. This
means that they’re still hyperfocused on growth,
everyone has to wear multiple hats, and most
importantly, they run a lean ship. Of course,
silicon valley startups rarely do any of this,
but traditionally, this is how a startup would
operate. Amazon is arguably the most infamous
company making these claims, and in one regard,
it’s true. Whether you’re a tech worker or
a factory worker, Amazon is gonna work you
to the bone just like a startup. But, unlike
a startup, almost all of these companies also
engage in overhiring. And, we’re not talking about
overhiring a little here or a little there. No,
we’re talking about systemic overhiring of
tens of thousands of people. And it’s super
obvious too. Take Facebook for example.
At the end of 2019, they had a total of
45,000 employees. But, by September of 2022,
they had 87,000. This means that Facebook’s
employee count nearly doubled within these three
years. Facebook obviously doesn’t need twice as
many employees to run the same services that
were already massive three years ago or create
platforms that 38 people use. This usually isn’t
a big deal during bull markets when the market
is doing well and investors are happy. But,
during recessions, companies almost instantly
turn around and layoff everyone that they
overhired. Going back to Facebook, they laid off
11,000 people. Even companies that are doing
relatively well end up in this situation. Take
Google for example. Google’s net income has
barely dipped and is still hovering near all
time highs. Yet, Google is receiving significant
pressure to reduce their workforce, and there are
rumors that Google is looking to layoff 10,000
people. But, why even play this entire game?
Why hire to fire? Wouldn’t it make sense to run a
lean ship at all times like a startup? This way,
during good times, their profit margins will be
even higher, and during bad times, they won’t
have to shed too much of their workforce if any. I
mean, it seems pretty straightforward, yet most of
these companies still overhire. So, here’s why
companies overhire just to end up laying off.
FOMO:
Much of these corporations
hiring practices can be linked back to
one simple human emotion: fear, the fear
of missing out. During periods of hypergrowth,
it seems like everyone around you is investing
and growing way faster than you. This was very
much true for Amazon. From the pandemic bottom,
Amazon stock grew about 132% which is a great
number. But, from Amazon’s perspective, many of
their peers grew substantially more. Facebook
grew 180%, Google grew 200%, Apple grew 240%,
and heck even the S&P 500 grew 120%. Looking at
it like this, Amazon barely beat the market and
they significantly underperformed their peers.
Now, the smart thing to do would be to identify
areas in which Amazon could fundamentally grow.
But, oftentimes, what happens is they look at what
their peers are doing. And more times than not,
their peers are pouring crap loads of money into
research and development. For example, Facebook
was pouring a $100 billion into the Metaverse.
And when Amazon sees this, they think: Ah, that
must be the key. If we want to grow at the pace of
Facebook, we have to double down on R&D. And this
is how you end up with projects like Alexa that
are massive money pits. During bull markets, it’s
easy to say that these investments are for the
long haul, but when things turn around, it doesn’t
take long for companies to get a reality check.
Aside from overinvesting into R&D, companies
also end up overinvesting into marketing.
When companies realize that they're falling behind
their competitors, a natural response is to become
more aggressive with sales. This includes hiring
a bunch of sales people, pumping up ad budgets,
and creating overly generous referral programs.
This overinvestment is only made worse by the
positive feedback loops that follow. As
companies pump up marketing, it’ll actually
appear like the investment is worth it. They’ll
have great click through rates, conversion rates,
and customer acquisition costs, so they’ll end up
spending even more on marketing. They’ll also hire
a bunch of new developers, solutions architects,
and managers to keep up with this demand. But,
in reality, much of this growth can be explained
by consumer sentiment. As you’re probably aware,
the bull market FOMO doesn’t just affect
companies, it also affects the general
public. When you see your friends and family buy
new cars and houses, you naturally feel a sense
of security and safety as it feels like everything
goes well. This doesn’t mean that you go out and
buy a car yourself, but maybe, you might be a bit
more loose when it comes to your Amazon spending
or you might keep around subscriptions that
you don’t actually use. But, when a recession
rolls around and you see your friends and family
losing their jobs and struggling to make payments,
you’re naturally going to put off that iPhone
upgrade and eat out less. When companies see this,
it’ll appear as if their sales team is no
longer as effective. So, they’ll end up
scaling back their sales team which in turn
means scaling back the rest of the company.
DEFENSIVE:
It may not seem like it, but overhiring
is actually oftentimes a defensive move. Here’s
the thing, when things are going well, employees
are usually pretty confident. They’ll be willing
to ask for promotions, look for other jobs,
and join riskier organizations. And given that
everyone is chucking a bunch of money into sales
and R&D, it’s usually not that difficult for these
employees to find a better job. All of a sudden,
getting into the most prestigious companies won’t
be as impossible as it once seemed. And joining a
crypto brokerage won’t seem as irresponsible as
it once seemed. Also, we’re not talking about
nominal increases to your salary like going from
$60,000 to $70,000. We’re talking about jumps like
$70,000 to $120,000 or $150,000 to $280,000. I
mean, you just have to take one look at these
companies' salaries to understand just how much
their willing to pay to attract the best talent.
At the same time, even employees that don’t leave
will be more confident in setting boundaries.
While these guys ended up sticking around, they’re
usually well aware that they could switch just
like their peers. They probably also see a bunch
of vacancies around them which means that the
company is struggling to hire enough talent. All
of this shows that the employer is more dependent
on the employee than the employee is dependent
on the employer. This means that the employee is
unlikely to work outside of their regular hours
or take on work that’s outside their scope. This
is pretty much exactly what we were seeing till
recently. Everyone was resigning and switching
jobs or they were quiet quitting. Companies are
acutely aware of this, but they really can’t do
much about it. If they force their employees to
be more productive, more of them will probably
leave which will just mean that the company has
even more positions to fill likely at higher
salaries as well. To combat this, companies have
to overhire to account for the lower productivity
and higher churn. This was the case just one
year ago. At the end of 2021, Mark Zuckerberg was
irritated that Facebook wasn’t able to meet their
recruiting targets especially with experienced
engineers. In fact, Facebook was struggling to
get even half of their applicants to accept job
offers despite literally offering millions.
But, this entire dynamic turns on its head
during a recessionary period. For one, employees
are not only less likely to leave but they’re also
more likely to be productive because they wanna
keep their jobs. This suddenly means that you
can accomplish all of the same tasks with just
70 or 80% of your workforce. At the same time,
new hires start piling up. Before, you had to
recruit like crazy just to maintain your headcount
and account for the massive churn. But now, all
of these new hires quickly become a deadweight for
the company. For example, let’s say the company
was overhiring by 10%. If their existing staff
suddenly becomes 30% more productive, the company
is no longer overstaffed by just 10%, they’re
overstaffed by 40%. And, at this point, there’s
nothing left to do but bring out the chopper.
HIRE TO FIRE:
The points that
we’ve discussed so far are pretty understandable.
During bull markets, companies are often fearful
of falling behind and they’re forced to overhire
just to keep up. When market dynamics shift,
however, this often results in massive layoffs.
While this no doubt sucks, it’s atleast somewhat
understandable. What’s not understandable,
however, is the third subset of reasons
that companies overhire which is the nefarious
subset. One of the most nefarious of these is the
practice of hiring to fire. At first glance,
this probably sounds super counterintuitive,
and it is. Why would anyone spend so much time,
money, and effort into vetting and interviewing
thousands of applicants just to turn around
and fire them? Well, let’s just say, it’s not
something that anyone really wants to do, but
certain corporate policies make this a reality.
For example, Amazon requires that the bottom 10%
of their workforce be let go on an annual basis.
If you’re an Amazon manager, this would be easy to
do if you have a crappy worker on your team. But,
unfortunately, most Amazon managers aren’t that
lucky given that everyone that they hire for the
corporate side are exceptional. If they were to
score their team members, the worst performer
might be given a 90%. Obviously, there’s some room
for improvement here, but it’s definitely not a
fireable offense. Managers very much understand
that this would be unfair and that’s why they
turn to hiring to fire. They usually maintain
a core team of 7 to 10 people that they want
to keep permanently. And every year, they’ll
hire some random sucker who will be tasked
with doing all the dirty work for the team for
a year before getting fired. If a given sucker
truly does an exceptional job, there is a chance
that they’ll be allowed to stick around, but this
means that someone else on the team now has to
be fired instead and this is by design. A lot of
companies don’t care about tenure or experience.
In fact, they feel like these attributes make an
employee less productive because they become too
comfortable. These companies would much rather
have a bunch of short term employees that work
their butts off the entire time they’re there.
And this forces managers to either hire to fire
or hire to replace. It’s truly quite a vicious
practice, but it’s not just Amazon who’s guilty
of this. Most old school corporate giants practice
some form of this. Think companies like GE, IBM,
and even Microsoft up until 2013. We should note,
however, that it wasn’t till after 2013 that
Microsoft finally started to grow again. So, this
practice is definitely just as counterproductive
as it sounds. But, nonetheless, many companies
still practice it leading to constant
overhiring followed by layoffs and firing.
WHY COMPANIES OVERHIRE:
In the end, while it might be easy to say that
companies should just hire what they need, it’s
usually not that simple. The underlying problem
is that the number of employees that a company
needs is simply not constant. When everyone is
spending and buying, companies naturally need
more employees. Conservely, when everyone is
pulling back, companies need less employees.
Combine this with varying levels of productivity
and opportunities and this issue just becomes
even more magnified. But, this doesn’t mean that
companies are completely innocent either. Many of
them engage in terrible practices like hiring to
fire or hiring to replace which not only increases
churn, but also creates a horrendous workplace
culture which makes the entire organization less
productive. Really, the only way to avoid this
is to join some sort background company like an
energy company or a water company or of course
the government. But for the rest of us, well,
we’ll probably have to deal with these corporate
games throughout the rest of our careers, but
that’s just what I think. What are your thoughts
on hiring to fire? Comment that down below. Also,
drop a like if you’re hoping that the layoffs end
sooner rather than later. And of course consider
checking out our discord community to suggest
future video ideas and consider subscribing
to see more questions logically answered.